in the opening scene we learn that a
Havoc has spread across the globe and
the scientists term it as a solar crisis
as the sun becomes an expanding redit
giant it threatens to engulf the Earth
within 100 years to avert this
catastrophe the United Nations now known
as the United Earth government or the
ueg introduces the moving Mountain
project the primary goal of this project
is to build 10,000 massive nuclear
fusion engines that can Propel the Earth
out of the solar system towards another
habitable star system despite the
Project's Noble intent it is completely
idiotic and its high operational costs
and excessive resource consumption cause
riots and protests from people who don't
care about tragedy that isn't happening
yet the protests get even more intense
when the ueg shuts down and bans the
Digital Life project or the DLP one that
proposes continuing human civilization
through digital immortality by
developing mind uploading Technologies
in retaliation the well-armed DLP
constantly hacks and throws terrorist
attacks at the ueg at one point the ueg
notices that people are losing faith in
their project and considers stopping it
however a Chinese Ambassador named z ji
convinces everyone to carry on as the
first part of the moving Mountain
project the lunar Exile program is
initiated that focuses on pushing the
Moon away from the Earth for this it
utilizes three fusion engines in order
to minimize the moon's gravitational
pull many people are being trained as
astronauts for this task one of them is
Leu Pang who arrives at the space
elevator base surrounded by the
protesters the armed guards are on duty
to prevent these protesters from
entering the area however one of them
somehow manages to break in but he is
soon subdued by a trainy astronaut named
Han duo duo Leu is instantly captivated
by her and already imagines a future
with her surely the chances of this are
decent in a world where pushing the moon
with rockets helps fix a problem with
the sun following this the new trainees
are escorted to the space elevator for
their first test this elevator is the
highest structure in human history that
provides a glimpse of space to the
trainee as they get on board it goes up
so fast that many of them faint on the
way as the days pass by they are trained
in various subject matters such as
hand-to-hand combat firearm usage and
fre elevator trips until they don't pass
out anymore they're also put through
medical tests and exercises to make sure
they're in Peak physical condition
during their training Leu and Han
develop a close Bond and enjoy one
another's company one day he bribes the
guards with some packs of cigarettes to
allow him to bring a flower bouquet
inside the base they happily accept the
cancer from the S he then gives it to
Han but it leads to an awkward moment as
they're watched by everyone on the same
day a new set of train arrives at the
base and joins the previous group at the
space elevator unexpectedly all the
drones begin to fly on their own and the
engineers discover that their system has
been hacked soon after the drones open
fire at the base forcing the guards to
fire back at their own Tech in defense
the ueg deploys several fighter planes
to take down the Hacked drones but
airplanes won't aim at them because
they're detected as allies in the
meantime the trainees including Leu and
Han are trapped in one of the space
elevators that goes up ahead of schedule
here it's revealed that the new trainees
are none other than highly trained
infiltrators who soon start stealing the
IDS of the former trainees shortly after
Leu uses his glasses to make the Sun
burn the lock screen causing the door to
open he then starts fighting the
infiltrators one after another a while
Later Han hands him a mechanical arm
with the help of which he knocks out all
of The Intruders back at the base the
scientists bring the 550c the latest
intelligent quantum computer that
finally counteracts the hacking however
it's too late because the hijackers have
successfully managed to attach a missile
to one elevator thanks to counterfeit
passes as a result the top of the space
elevator and the arc space station are
critically damaged and crash Down to
Earth this results in irreparable damage
to the base and many of the trainees in
this process Leu jumps on top of Han and
shields her from any arm but not from
the protrusion in his pantaloons in the
aftermath of this event the base is
evacuated while the news reports
confirmed the loss of over 3,000 lives
riots intensify in the following weeks
because of all the death and resource
depletion public demand increases for
the reinstatement of the DLP due to this
attack many countries working on the
pilot program pull out leaving China
alone to take on finishing construction
of the lunar and Earth engine XE
instructs his assistant to deliver the
speech he's prepared urging faith in the
project while he engages in discussions
with the American ambassador to convince
him to give them a chance the scene then
cuts to the Moon where the lunar Exile
pilot program is in progress there a
computer engineer named Tu hangu wakes
up from his hibernation pod and proceeds
to inspect the systems he also sets up
his quantum computer called AI 550a
coincidentally also the name of Elon
musk's 36th son that enables him to
watch a video of his late daughter Yaya
recorded 5 years ago H Yu formerly
associated with the DLP had managed to
record and store his daughter's
Consciousness on a hard drive with his
mentor and Project Lead ma Xiao bearing
the responsibility hu now aspires to
transform Yaya's brief video clip into a
complete AI form for this he opts using
the newer 550c but is outright rejected
by Xiao afterwards the two do the first
testing of 5 50c by activating each
sector of the base while they wait for
the computer to do its thing Xiao gives
hu the digital copy of his mind which
the company confiscated when they banned
the DLP Xiao explains that it's up to
him if he wants to destroy it or not
sometime later the system detects an
incoming solar storm forcing all the
workers to rush back to the base they
drive their vehicles as fast as they can
and manage to enter the base moments
before the storm hits but unfortunately
the AI 550c gets damaged in this process
since they need a quantum computer to
launch the project hu offers to use his
550a in return he asks Xiao to involve
him in all the future developments of
the 550 series hoping that he'll have a
chance to give Yaya a complete life as
soon as Xiao accepts hang Yu transfers
his daughter's Consciousness recording
to a disc before handing over his AI
computer 3 days later the team tests the
engines and after moments of tension
they're delighted to witness a slight
angular displacement of the moon this
proves that in 20 years they'll be able
to push the Moon away completely the
success restores people's faith in the
project several months later they again
conduct another test of the engines this
time on Earth at first all the screens
go black and people think it's failed
but suddenly the ground shakes and a
bright beam emanates from the astronaut
base not long after the ueg scientists
confirm Earth's angular displacement
bringing immense Joy to the populace
after successful Trials of both the
lunar engine the ueg grants full go
ahead to the moving Mountain project as
the mission progresses it officially
gets renamed as the wandering Earth over
the next 14 years more than 7,000
engines are constructed including torque
engines that slow down the Earth's
rotation making it 60 hours per day
furthermore the Subterranean cities are
built under every engine in order to
provide shelter for ordinary Citi
citizens for the anticipated
2500e Interstellar Journey however there
is also talk about a sortition plan in
which only 50% of the world's population
can gain a spot in the underground
cities and the requirements to get a
pass are quite discriminatory as time
goes on the solar crisis becomes more
and more imminent evidenced by spikes in
solar radiation all kinds of weather
disasters soon hit the planet like
floods moreover the people also suffer
from increas Ed cancer cases due to
solar radiation on the other hand Liu
has married Han and they now have a son
named key like other people they are
also worried about getting the passes
for the underground cities to make
matters worse Han has been diagnosed
with cancer in the meantime henu never
stops working on Yaya's AI form while
also helping with the development of the
newest and most advanced 550 series
iteration called 550 W otherwise known
as the common light bulb one day Leu who
has now secured the rank of major is
summoned for an interview to determine
his eligibility for a pass the interview
is conducted by an offline AI equipped
550w who acknowledges Leo's impressive
skills but suggests he stay on Earth to
care for his family despite this Leu
makes a tough decision to accept the
pass because it's the only way to take
his son to the Subterranean cities
through preferential policy the
scientists in charge of the project are
watching the interview from the other
room and Liu's affection towards his son
reminds hangu of his daughter the AI
also suggests that it's better not to
fight for the past for Leo's wife
predicting her passing in 83 days
unfortunately this infuriates Leo and he
ends up yelling at the scientists
resulting in him failing the test
outright later on he spends Time with
Han who is now hospitalized as they
Converse Han expresses her wish to see
her hometown One Last Time hearing this
Leo arranges for a a Jet Plane from a
fellow comrade and takes her to her
hometown after a while of Joyful flight
they land in Shanghai which is now
turned into a frozen Wasteland that
night while gazing at the stars Han says
that when the time comes she wants to
die with dignity and not with a bunch of
wires and pipes connected to her
meanwhile at the base hangu having been
influenced by Liu P Kang's Outburst
decides to upload Yaya's recorded
Consciousness into the 550w
supercomputer as a result Yaya finally
starts conversing with him daddy I can
see your incognito search history
breaking him down into tears however
right after the upload the lunar engines
experience an overload resulting in an
explosion that propels the moon on a
collision course with Earth the guards
then use tasers to subdue hu and arrest
him for his unlawful acts zuu is near
the ocean when it happens as a
consequence of the explosion a tsunami
grows in size and hits the land
recognizing the impending danger he
issues an emergency alert to leaders all
over the globe Leu also gets notified of
this emergency and is summoned back to
duty meanwhile the ueg uses their 550w
supercomputers to avert the danger but
to no avail as a result they resort to
opening the underground cities to let
people in before Leu leaves for the
mission Han succumbs to her illness and
their son is taken to the underground
city by his grandfather afterwards Z
talks at the ueg asking for their
support for his emergency plan he wants
to detonate all of the Earth's nuclear
weapons on the moon to induce nuclear
fusion within its core leading to
implosion no government has ever
revealed how many nuclear weapons they
have in their Arsenal because it's
confidential and nobody likes revealing
the size of their nuclear PP but for the
first time in history it doesn't matter
convinced by this plan everyone agrees
to hand in what what they have in order
to save the world elsewhere Xiao visits
the imprisoned hu to tell him that
they'll be activating Earth's engines
soon so they need to reactivate the
global internet to allow coordinated
detonation control one of the servers is
now submerged underwater and Xiao wants
hang Yu to handle it when the ladder
tries to refuse Xiao blackmails him with
using the disc with Yaya's digital
Consciousness as if he hasn't uploaded a
backup by this point due to the lunar de
forming an asteroid belt around the moon
the best Pilots are chosen to transport
the nuclear weapons including Leu
simultaneously three teams are
dispatched to recover the missing
internet servers located in Beijing
Tokyo and Dillis not long after the
chosen Pilots leave for the moon trying
their best to dodge the incoming
asteroids along their way despite their
best efforts some shuttles get hits
causing them to crash this leads the
team to lose 200 Warheads only leaving
180 for detonation shortly after the U's
shuttle also hits an asteroid and
crashes on the moon's surface the
survivors immediately search for tape to
fix their helmets to keep up oxygen and
bandage any wounds following this they
decide to deliver the remaining Warheads
on foot Leo prioritizing his teammates
safety uses an abandoned Lander to send
them back to the base while he stays
behind to set up the WarHeads back on
Earth the three teams reach the server
locations and dive underwater using
drones and special ized tools hu's team
in Beijing gains access to the server
room there they immediately start
working on the necessary steps to
restore the internet around this time
lunar debris starts striking Earth with
one directly hitting beijing's data
center flooding the insides the shock
results in a tangle of thick wires
falling on xia's leg trapping him there
he immediately summons hangu for help
but a jammed door prevents the ladder
from entering at last Xiao makes a brave
move he pass passes a password key to
hangu and instructs him to leave the
debris reeks Havoc destroying cities
worldwide leading to panic as people
Rush towards the underground cities at
the ueg Z learns that they can't
detonate all the Warheads at the same
time due to diverse models some even
requiring 712 hours as a result of this
Joe is about to lose hope when one of
his men comes up with a solution
dispatching more astronauts to the Moon
to trigger the WarHeads manually however
it's a one-way ticket because they would
have to sacrifice their lives for the
same following this XE assembles all of
his astronauts and reveals this as the
only option despite the known life risk
all Brave astronauts volunteer to go at
the same time an older astronaut points
out it's their duty to do this and leave
the younger ones to take care of the
future with this decision 300 astronauts
over the age of 50 board the shuttles
and make their way to the moon on the
moon Leu completes the Warhead setup but
is surprised to see additional arriving
astronauts sadly he can't communicate
with them due to his damaged
Communicator being a younger astronaut
he is sent back to the Earth via a
spacecraft the ueg confirms the Tokyo
and dullas servers are back online but
not Beijing turns out that hangu is
struggling with connecting the key to
the computer as water fills his room as
well realizing that he doesn't have long
before drowning he uploads a copy of his
own recorded Consciousness into the
Network simultaneously the astronauts on
the moon detonate all the WarHeads
finally imploding the moon and averting
Collision however more debris comes
towards Earth necessitating Swift action
by the scientists to propel the planet
meanwhile the water covers the entire
room causing hangu to drown to death
with the realization that their mission
is failed the uig issues a final goodbye
message instigating Widespread Panic
however we learned that the mission
isn't over yet because hu's digital mind
activates inside the computer it
reunites with his daughter and together
they proceed to work on activating the
server they managed to activate it in
the neck of time moving the Earth away
from the course of the lunar debris
everyone breathes a sigh of relief and
celebrates their success while the tides
calm down the scene then advances s
years into the future depicting that
Earth has restored its 24-hour system
Joe has retired with his assistant
assuming leadership at the ueg now the
wandering Earth Project has officially
set sail in their next Journey aiming
for Jupiter the plan entails using one
final Boost from Jupiter to propel Earth
permanently out of the solar system for
good a space station is established to
review and control the engines with Leu
taking charge in a mid- credit scene
hu's digital self is addressed by AI
550w who now goes by the personified
name Moss the nas sentient supercomputer
discloses its role in destroying the
lunar engines and orchestrating numerous
hack attacks in the past Moss also
contends that the best way to preserve
human civilization is by destroying
mankind subscribe for more videos like
this turn on notifications and leave a
like to help the channel out thank you
for watching